Hello Everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica!
Now! Starting off as we did in the last one, I have a few new names to add to my wall
The first one is Luke K.
who said, "waits in hope that Mark will encounter the Sea Emperor."
And I don't know what the sea emperor is... so...
Holy crap, is that a new creature?
Was that added to the game?
I have no idea but it sounds terrifying
The next one goes to Stefen RG, which- who said
"Hahaha the Fuck A Duck is going deep"
That just made me laugh
and then, Ernesto Cortez
so I'm just gonna put Ernesto
said, "don't worry Mark, take your time with the game, we appreciate what you do for us."
And I really appreciate that because
I love to take my time with this game because there's a lot of exploration to be done
I mean I'm going to put the farming off-camera always
But I-I just-
There's something very peaceful - and terrifying! - about the game when you go into the ocean
Because of how well crafted it is
how well rounded it is, the sound effects
All the different, like, aspects of the game come together to make a very interesting -
That's not very far away
...interesting experience
Before I go there,
I'm going to repair my doo-dad
Nope- I'm gonna repair my doodad
Imma repair the Fuck A Duck
And we're going to figure out what the hell this land mass is
Because when I hear "Land Mass" I think of island
Now this better actually be something
and not a whole lot of nothing
Okay it's going off into a direction that I've never been before
Is this... could this... Is it really?
Really?
Wow, okay
Alright I'm with it
I'm hip
I'm happenin, I'm doing it
I'm ready to does it
I'm ready to see what the hell this is
Holy crap
Could it really have been so close? If I had j-
I've gone in this direction before but deep underwater
I never bothered to look up
I mean-
I'm a little...
I'm- OH MY GOD
WHAT THE HELL
That was there the whole time? What the hell?
Did that-
Wha-wh-wha-
Where'd that come from?
Was that just not going to appear unless I found - whaat??
Wait is that an observatory already on there?
what is with this??
What are you?
What are you???
Oh my god
How did I miss this??
Its huge!!
It's covered in brine
It's got floaty ball sacs!
Ahhh, it's pulsating!!
Its got pulsating floaty ballsacks...
...that disappear when you're not lookin'
Oh my god
Holy crap
What the buck
fuck a duck
Landing...The Fuck A Duck has landed
I don't know if I'm going to be able to get it off the dirt there
Hopefully I can push it
There we go
You be free
I'll be back
What the hell
What the heelll?
what the hell
What? Pink flower?
Oh my god
It's beautiful!
Whoa
Cool!
Wha-orange mushroom?
Yes I will scan you
Dink
And I swear that's an observatory on there
Why is there an observatory on the top of the mountain peak?
And how do i get up there?
I'm used to swimming underwater I'm not used to this climbing stuff
I haven't used my legs in weeks
months even
All my muscles have atrophied and are about to fall off my bones
Hello
whoa-hey-whoa
Cyclops pressure compensator!
That is the depth module for the cyclops
So that, that particular thing -
That is a little odd
that particular thing that I just scanned is going to allow my Cyclops to go down deeper underwater
what are you?
Purple rattle?
I don't know what that means
I don't know what scanning this is all about
Okay
what are you?
It's nothing! It's green and makes me vibrate
Old cooked, it's not THAT old
Gosh
Alright then
What the heck
Can I get a sample of this?
Orange mushroom spore
It's big!
Why is it big?
I've been asked that many times before
shut up everybody
Okay
Something I can-? Nope that's nothing
Oh, I can see the Aurora from here
That's so weird you'd think I would've noticed this-
this giant fricken island here, long long ago
Can I- what's the climbing mechanics of this game
Oh, schnikies
I don't know if there's any fall damage to be had
But I don't want to experience it if its true
Wh- That's so pretty!!!
Oh my god I wanna dive into it
but i don't wanna lose m-
oh god d-
AHHHH
NO CHOICE! Here we go!
Ahh shit
Oh, that was cool
Ohhh that's so cool!
oh my god
This is amazing
Okay
So
Obvi-pff
Something wrong with your arm there buddy?
Something a little,
A little twitchy with what you got going on  there?
I don't know if that's supposed to be happening
Okay so I'm going to try to get to one of the observatories
I will be right back unless I find something worth finding
And then you guys will see it and me
probably screaming in fear of it because I'm screaming in fear of everything
purple vase plant?
Purple vase plant.
Why am i filling up my inventory with giant seeds that i-
oh, hello.
Hang on
whoa
That..
Wow.
That is a very old habitat
Now whose-
marblemelon?
Marblemelon?
Can I eat that?
I can eat that!
Whoa, I can eat that
What the heck?
Okay I'm gonna drop the mushroom spore and the-
I'm gonna drop these because there's plenty of them around
Especially the pink flower ones
But I'm gonna keep these marblemelons because that was a-
Okay apparently those are a mystery but that was
not...yeah..
Whoa, what the?
I could farm?!
These are HUGE
I shouldn't have picked them up
Ohh my god
Oh thats so cool
okay you stay there
This is a better source of food than I've ever had
Oh. Oh my god hello
"This is Chief Executive Officer of the Torlegickelyageon Corporation"
"The crew and I were marooned here five weeks ago"
"Our ship was struck by a projectile of unknown origins"
"There are three of us left"
"We constructed a habitat using materials reclaimed from the ship"
"We survived by cultivating indigenous flora"
"the biochemistry imprint I commissioned for my son has already paid for itself"
"He has grown enough food to last us a month"
Sounds familiar
Sounds like exactly what i was doing
"Now i fear for our safety,"
"A mercenary I hired for the journey has grown increasingly disturbed since losing her mate in the crash"
"She insists we abandon the site and establish a deep ocean base"
Now why would that be?
Thats what I did
"Against my better judgment I've agreed to come with her"
Okayy...
"Please come for us"
"Night time approaches."
I don't think that was part of the message but
Does that mean that they
they have another hidden base somewhere underground? Because- uh-underwater? Because
That would be ridiculous
And amazing. I would be SO down for that
And oh my god it's night time I can't even see a goddamn thing.
Let's see if we can use this.
Oh it got a lot creepier in the middle of the night,
it was a very lovely,
lovely, lovely,
lovely, lovely
island.
Now it's spooky.
My elbows don't bend down.
I can't flex my arms 90 degrees downward.
It would be too painful.
Alright, there's a path up this mountain
Which I can only assume is gonna lead to
another observational base
somewhere around here,
or it's going to allow me to plummet to my death.
One or the other.
I'm up for anything tonight.
Is that a..?
I can't tell if there's a gap.
There is a gap.
If I walked into that it would be my doom.
God dammit night.
What are you?
Hello. That's different.
Well that wasn't there be-
That is Earth's moon!
You can't fool me developers
that is literally Earth's moon.
Why is that there?
I've never, ever, ever seen that before
in this game.
Ever.
This is the first time you and I have
ever spoken Moon.
And this is where the complete
ocean insanity takes hold.
And I lose my god damn mind.
Okay, almost there, almost there, almost there.
Hello! We made it! Yes! Okay. Hello.
Ah, more plants. More food. Marblemelon
I don't know how to grow you myself
but, whoa.
Hello.
Why do I have a scannable here?
Scan chair? Really? Scan chair?
Okay...
I'm taking your word for this one, I dont know
what happened here. Was there a murder or something?
Starship chair blueprint..?
Yeah! I can make a chair!
My life is complete! Oh joyous day!
My time in the ocean has been not for...naught!
Okay, anyway. Desk. I didn't know that I could
scan these.
Okay, so that was good but what I'm not
seeing here...
I'm not seeing...
is any sort of-
Spotlight?
-is any sort of other audio log,
or something like that to explain
what the hell happened here.
And why did someone set up an
observation area on the top of this mountain?
It just seems obtuse and difficult.
I mean it's a great view don't get me wrong.
It's a fantastic view and I want to get to
the other mountain but
I mean, just the loneliness got to people
and they had to build a base up here
just to try to feel nor- Whoa!
Just to try to feel normal?
I do not know if there is fall damage but
I have a funny feeling that I'm going to break my legs.
Okay, nevermind. I'm going to be a-okay.
Everything's fine.
Everything's fine, everything's good.
Everything is good.
Okay, back to the other one.
Ahh, without dying preferably.
But that does explain a lot of things
and I would be willing to bet that somewhere,
somewhere,
in the deepest,
farthest reaches of the ocean there is
a base-
Oh, god.
-there is a base where these people left
uh, following the leadership of the mercenary
who lost her mate.
You know..
I don't know why I referred to her
partner as mate...that's a little,
a little odd vernacular for humans
because we don't usually call them that, but whatever.
It's fine.
Oh, hello. Thank you.
I could have been on top of the world there apparently.
Still can...oh boy.
That is a precarious thing.
Makes me launch into the air.
Whoa! Okay! Let's not!
Let's not tumble head over heels off the edge
of the island just yet.
But there is something else over there..
That...Oh, that's a bird.
Wow, I can literally see
forever up here.
That is nuts.
Oh, my goodness.
Wow.
I mean...
Wow. Okay, anyway back into the building
where we need to find something.
Disinfected water.
Anything else?
Wow. Holy crap.
Hanging fruit, that sounds amazing.
Can I make one of these?
If I plant one of these inside my base
can I do this?
Sounds...Oh it's so cool.
I mean obviously it's just flora and fauna
but where can I get this stuff for my base?
I mean, I could make a base
on this island. I could. I could make a base and
this could be an infinite su-
Old?
It's still good. Oh, that's what I get for picking it.
Eh..
Good enough.
Decomposed...I'm going to drop these.
I'm just going to leave these here.
They're just going to spoil and ruin the entire plant here.
Man, but this is good.
This is so good. This is like an infinite source of food.
So long as that actually does regrow.
This is very good.
Holy crap. Can I get up here?
Err..
NO!
Okay, so that's all the time that I got for this episode.
AH!
OH GOD!
Oh. We're fine. Everything is fine.
So, thank you everybody so much for joining me.
In the next episode I'm going to make a base
on this island because
This is just too good to pass up.
There is so much cool stuff here to explore
and it just adds a completely different dynamic
and it appeals to me
as a human
that I want to put my feet on solid land.
There might even be, like a cave in here because
there was a way to get down to that swimming pool
in the-
Swimming pool...
That's my swimming pool in my backyard.
On my private island where my friends are fish
and plants.
Anyway.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you in the next video.
Bye-Bye